let's say i have some object that's
traveling in a circular path just like
this and what i've drawn here is its
velocity vector at different points
along that path and so this right over
here is going to be v1
velocity vector one and this is going to
be velocity vector two
and this right over here is going to be
velocity vector three and we're going to
assume in this video is that the
magnitude of these velocity vectors is
constant or another way to think about
the speed is constant so i'll just say
lowercase v without the arrow on top so
this is going to be a scalar quantity
i'll call this the speed or you could
call this the magnitude of these vectors
and this is going to be constant so this
is going to be equal to the magnitude of
vector 1
which is equal to the magnitude of
vector 2. the direction is clearly
changing but the magnitude is going to
be the same which is equal to the
magnitude the magnitude of vector 3. and
we're going to assume that it's
traveling in a path in a circle with
radius r what i'm going to do is i'm
going to draw a position vector at each
point so let's call
let's call r1 actually i'll just do it
in pink let's call r1
that right over there
that's position vector 1 r1
that is position vector r2 so the
position is clearly changing
that's position vector r2 and that is
position vector r3 but the magnitude of
our position vectors are clearly the
same and i'm going to call the magnitude
of our position vectors r and that's
just the radius of the circle it's this
distance right over here so r is equal
to the magnitude of r1 which is equal to
the magnitude of r2
which is equal to the magnitude
magnitude of r3 now what i want to do in
this video is prove to you visually that
given this radius and given this speed
that the magnitude of the centripetal
acceleration and i'll just write that as
a sub c i don't have an arrow on top so
this is a scalar quantity so the
magnitude of the centripetal
acceleration is going to be equal to
our speed squared our constant speed
squared divided by
divided by the radius of the circle this
is what i want you
i want you to feel good that this is
indeed the case by the end of this video
and to understand that what i want to do
is i want to re-plot these these
velocity vectors on another circle and
just think about how the vectors
themselves are changing so let's copy
and paste this so let me copy and paste
v1
so copy
and paste so that is v actually i want
to do it from the center so that is v1
then we do the same thing for v2
so let me copy
and paste it
that is v2
and then let me do it also for v3
so v3 i'll just get the vector part i
don't have to get the label so copy and
paste it and that right over there is
vector v3 and let me clean this up a
little bit just so that we don't so
that's clearly v2 i don't think we have
to label anymore we know that v2 is in
orange we know that v2 is an orange and
what is the radius of this circle going
to be right over here well the radius of
this circle is going to be the magnitude
of the velocity vectors and we already
know the magnitude of the velocity
vectors is this quantity v the scalar
quantity so the radius of this circle
is v the radius of this circle we
already already know is equal to r
and just as the velocity vector is
what's giving us the change in position
over time the change in position vector
over time what's the vector that's going
to give us the change in our velocity
vector over time well that's going to be
our acceleration vectors so you will
have some acceleration
we'll call this a1
we'll call this
a2
a2 and i'll call this a3 a3 and i want
to make sure that you get the analogy
that's going on here as we go around in
this circle the position vectors first
they point out to the left then the
upper up kind of into the kind of at a
maybe 11 o'clock position or i guess the
top the the top left then to the top so
it's pointing in these different
directions like a hand and a clock and
what's moving it along there is the
change in position vector over time
which is are these velocity vectors over
here the velocity vectors are moving
around like the hands of a clock and
what it what is doing the moving around
is
are these acceleration vectors and over
here the velocity vectors they are
tangential to the radius or sorry
they're tangential to the path which is
a circle they're perpendicular to a
radius and you learn that in geometry
that a that a line that is tangent to a
circle is perpendicular to a radius and
it's also going to be the same thing
right over here and just going back to
what we learned when we learned about
the intuition of centripetal
acceleration if you look at a1 right
over here and you translate this vector
it'll be going just like that it is
going towards the center a2 once again
is going towards the center a3 once
again if you translate that that is
going towards the center so all of these
are actually center seeking vectors and
you see that right over here these are
all these are actually centripetal
acceleration vectors right over here
here we're talking about just the
magnitude of it and we're going to
assume that all of these have the same
magnitude so we're going to assume
that our centripetal they all have the
magnitude that we'll call a sub c so
that's the magnitude it's equal to the
magnitude of a1
that vector it's equal to the magnitude
of a2
and it's equal to the magnitude of a3
now what i want to think about is how
long is it going to take for this thing
to get from this point on this circle to
that point on that circle right over
there
so the way to think about it is what's
the length of the arc that it traveled
the length of this arc that it traveled
right over there that's one-fourth
around the circle it's going to be
one-fourth of the circumference
the circumference is 2 pi r it is going
to be 1 4 of that
so that is the length of the arc
that is the length of the arc and then
how long will it take it to go that well
you would you divide the length of your
path divided by the actual speed the
actual thing that's nudging it along
that path so you want to divide that by
your actual the magnitude of your
velocity or your speed this is magnitude
of velocity not velocity this is not a
vector right over here this is a scalar
so this is going to be the time the time
to travel along that path
now that the time of travel along this
path is going to be the exact same
amount of time it takes to travel along
this path for the velocity vector so
this is for the position vector to
travel like that this is for the
velocity vector to travel like that so
it's going to be the exact same t
and what is the length of this path and
now think of it in the purely
geometrical sense we look we're looking
at a circle here the radius of this
circle is v so the length of this path
right over here is going to be 1 4
is going to be i'll do it in that same
color so you see the analogy it's equal
to 1 4 times the circumference of this
circle the circumference of this circle
is 2 pi
times the radius of the circle which is
v
now what is nudging it along this circle
what is nudging along this path what is
the analogy for speed right over here
speed is what's nudging along the path
over here it is the magnitude of the
velocity vector so it's nudging along
this arc right over here is the
magnitude of the acceleration vector so
it is going to be
it is going to be a sub c and these
times are going to be the exact same
thing the amount of time it takes to go
for this vector to go like that for the
position vector is the same amount of
time it takes except the velocity vector
to go like that so we can set these two
things equal each other so we get on
this side we get 1 4
2 pi
r
over v
is equal to
1 4 2 pi v
2 pi v
over
over the magnitude of our acceleration
vector
and now we can simplify a little bit we
can divide both sides by 1 4. get rid of
that we can divide both sides by 2 pi
get rid of that let me rewrite it so
then we get r over v is equal to v
over the centripetal acceleration and
now you could cross multiply and so you
get v times v
so i'm just multiplying
i'm cross multiplying right over here v
times v you get v squared is equal to ac
times r and cross multiplying remember
is really just the same thing as
multiplying both sides by both
denominators by multiplying both sides
times v and ac
times v
and ac so it's not some magical thing if
you multiply both sides times v and ac
these v's cancel out these ac's cancel
out you get
v times v is v squared is equal to a sub
c times r
is equal to
a sub c times r and now to solve for the
magnitude of our centripetal
acceleration
you just divide both sides by r
you divide both sides by r and you are
left with and i i guess we we've earned
a drum roll now you are left with the
magnitude of our centripetal
acceleration is equal to the magnitude
our constant magnitude of our velocity
so this right here is our speed divided
by the radius of the circle and we're
done